[Musik]
simak noch in staus unfälle pannen
stress pur für die brummifahrer
drei von ihnen geben einblick in ihr
leben auf achse
hd für schwertransport immer nur nachts
immer allein ständig etwas kaputt keine
taktik nirgendwo erich fehr termin
fracht ihm bleibt nichts erspart
von einem kunden zum nächsten immer
unter termindruck ein leben gegen die
uhr
[Musik]
transportiert autos er will am
wochenende heiraten steht gewaltig unter
stress denn manchmal geht aber auch
alles schief
essen ist nicht mehr trinken ikonisch
mehr
es ist einfach nur nach feierabend nur
noch meinen besten drei männer und der
immer härter werden derzeit auf
deutschen autobahnen
[Musik]
ks touren beginnen oder enden fast immer
hier
bremerhaven ist der größte autor
umschlagplatz europas mehr als zwei
millionen pkw werden hier jährlich
verschifft oder an geänderten sich aus
mit den edlen und den einfachen karossen
egal ob links oder rechts gelenkt werden
auf schaltgetriebe oder automatik ist
bekannt für seine lage künste aber er
muss verdammt aufpassen sonst kann es
teuer werden
also ganz schlimm sind wie automatik und
der dabei wenn die automatik hast denn
reagiert die nicht so als wenn du jetzt
normal warm ist also die da läuft nicht
fließen sondern die hat schon mal so
luftloch und er kann passieren wenn du
arm bist musst anhalten tritt auf gast
kommt erst gar nichts und dann kommt so
richtig da muss natürlich berichtigung
und auch ein bisschen von bremerhaven
aus startet mit seinem truck zu händlern
in der ganzen republik
immer wieder montags gibt er gummi heute
etwas mehr weil er schon hinter zug ist
und weil diese woche eine ganz besondere
ist aber freitag ist nun die hochzeit
von meiner frau so jetzt muss man sehen
ein bisschen ziemlich später bremerhaven
wegkommen dass man natürlich aber zu
sein und muss ich ein bisschen
krachen lassen seit freitag pünktlich
nach hause schaffen ansonsten logik habe
ich ein ganz schwerer probleme mit
meiner zukünftigen frau und kann er
gleich wieder abblasen
also gegen die uhr wie immer aber
verschärft mit einem hochzeitstermin im
nacken
und dann geht der ärger los nichts geht
mehr 20 kilometer stau vor dass wir die
nerven
auf dem gelände der übersee werft in
bremerhaven hd fährt schwertransporte er
hat nur fünf stunden geschlafen die
ganze nacht war betrieb jetzt muss er
den bagger abladen der aufleger klemmt
ist schwer abzukoppeln
[Musik]
thomas sein begleiter hilft ihm aber er
ist hardy nicht schnell genug
der nächste termin sitzt ihm im nacken
hdi ist gewitzt so die schrittweise
übersteht weg absetzen vorfahren unter
klappern wir zusammen bauen unterschrift
abfahrt ist es aber nicht
fast jede maschine ist anders alles
hightech und harley muss es ohne
anleitung verstehen alles
computertechnik warten müssen die wii
fans
dann rollt das monster endlich hat alles
im griff
thomas zeigt ihm den weg jetzt haben sie
spaß zehn minuten auslauf für die ganz
großen jungs
[Musik]
das war service am kunden
seit 20 jahren transportiert keine autos
immer unter zeitdruck
die ganze woche verbringt er auf der
autobahn getrennt von frau und kindern
kein träumt vom familienleben aber er
liebt auch sein enkel kennt er
persönlich im moment da von mir selber
wie meine familie oder meine frau oder
welcher bekannten verbringen da über
jeden tag fünf stunden schlaf in neun
stunden also manche sachen hätte der
organe sehen wohin gläubig aber wir
haben schon persönlicher zeit ist der
wird auch montags über man turbo die
streicher blickte letzten wochen
nochmals die baustelle redet mit ihm
über seine funkfrequenz
[Musik]
von den schülern besonders das ist
einfach nur da sind wir wieder bei der
übermüdung falls irgendjemand übermüdet
an die pflaster kommt und die oben zu
hart weil der mutter durch die grelle
ihr euch eventuell noch mal geweckt dass
er da hinten die oft werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenige kilometer weiter blaulicht und
sirenen
es hat mal wieder gekracht später
erfährt er aus dem radio dass es ein
aufwand von mal mit toten
kai ist trotz seiner 20 jahre auf dem
bock ein abgebrühter zyniker er grübelte
über die ursachen
nach so einem unfall schnell zur
tagesordnung zurück geht für ihn nicht
[Musik]
meisten unfälle passieren nach wie vor
durch technik banker wie wenn er mal so
manche leute beobachtet ist beim fahren
da wird ein laptop gespielt oder handy
ganz große sache smartphone
da wären sachen während der fahrt
bestellt und origin sachen eu gilt das
klingt ab sommer wenn du denn so
steuerlast und cuxhaven wieder zum
sekunden aber man kann sich schon
passiert sei
die nacht zum tag machen das musst du
zuerst lernen wenn du schwertransporter
fährst sagt hardy
zwischen zwei und vier uhr ist tote hose
auf der autobahn hd kämpft gegen
müdigkeit und manchmal noch gegen die
schwermut was vielen dank zeit zum
nachdenken
und manchmal wird man eben zeit
depressiv
was ist da wirklich die ganze pfarrei
zum trotz so anstrengend nachts durch
die gegend zu fahren hat man halt mal
zeit
und dann fährt man stur hinter ähneln
daher weil ja nicht schneller ist ich
bin nicht stiller ich fand mich
überholen ich will ihn überholen weil
der funpark das vorbei die schlafen alle
das ist alles so
und wo deprimierend
auf und laster stehende ausschlafen
du treibst daraus herum
glücklich ist wer einen legalen
parkplatz ergattert hat ein riese wie
hardy hat morgens um sechs wenn seine
lenkzeit gelaufen ist oft keine chance
mehr
hardy versucht sein glück in einer
nothaltebucht mitten im norddeutschen er
muss aufhören
sein begleiter hilft ihm in die kleine
lücke es war höchste zeit
nicht nur weil nach sechs kein
schwerlaster seiner größe mehr fallen
darf 16 stunden pause hier ohne fließend
wasser und toilette
[Applaus]
erich altmüller fährt termin fracht er
liegt bereits einen halben tag hinter
seinem wochenplan
sein nächstes ziel ostende in belgien
in zehn minuten ist seine zeit
abgelaufen
dann beginnt die aufholjagd gerade noch
ein wenig zeit für die körperpflege
frühstück noch fünf minuten dann startet
er sein als victor lebensraum morgens
die küche und nachts eben das
schlafzimmer käfighaltung nannte es
gelegentlich auch und das seit 43 jahren
jetzt
7 millionen kilometer hat er auf dem
buckel doch bei allem ärger sich der von
diesem job nie losgekommen
es war einfach als kind mein traum weil
ich aus einer fuhrmanns familie stamme
mein großvater war schon mit pferden
fuhrmann und ich bin eigentlich mit
diesel im club geboren worden
ich war als kind lkw mit gefahren im
eltern groß geworden und alt geworden
in wenigen monaten gehe ich in rente dem
termin fährt er nicht so freudig
entgegen
dazu liegt er ich das leben auf achse
viel zu sehen auch wenn das leben auf
der autobahn immer gefährlicher wird
sascha goc
hier fällt alles durch was aus dem aus
osteuropa kommt und richtung niederlande
oder dem vater die a2 die berüchtigste
auto bauen und die also meiner meinung
nach auch die gefährlichste autobahn
wieder stau wieder nervosität wieder der
bange blick auf den wochenplan für die
planer in der firma ist es ganz einfach
am computer ist die straße immer frei
bei der disposition passt das am rechner
am computer am boden plane er passt das
aber die einflüsse der staus durch
verzögerungen sind erkennt kein computer
keine und das sind natürlich das ist das
ungewisse in diesem beruf man weiß nie
wo man am nächsten tag ist
keine trucker auf freiersfüßen holt auf
mittlerweile hat er gute aussichten ist
rechtzeitig zum standesamt zu schaffen
seine bisherigen beziehungen sind alle
gescheitert weil er so selten zu hause
war und er ist eifersüchtig ich bin
reifer sich nicht ich mache da nicht
mehr so wie früher gezeigt hat nicht
mehr weiter und dann habe ich bei der
hand wenn du zeigst du jetzt auf der
thema immer wieder ein du kannst du dir
sowieso nicht ändern wenn jemand mal
machen wir gemacht hat das erst mal fakt
aber ich bin schon eifersüchtig und ich
habe auch schon angst sie zu verlieren
ja keine frage die fahrt nach essen zu
einem großhändler verläuft zunächst
störungsfrei auch durch die innenstadt
rollt der verkehr reibungslos doch dann
ende der glückssträhne
es kommt faustdick für kai der platz des
händlers ist total überfüllt
mai kann stundenlang nicht abladen eine
pech hat so hat es der platzwart gesagt
kommt er erst morgen dran aber da hatte
einen dringenden termin auf dem
standesamt hilfesuchend wendet er sich
an seinen chef
[Musik]
ja es war ja jetzt können wir
wahrscheinlich heute gar nicht mehr
ablehnen weil der platz voll ist die
haben keine lagerkapazitäten mehr also
für jetzt das programm so wie es
aussieht erstmal heute strom gestern der
stau heute.de
daher kann wochen die weitergemacht weil
ich jetzt hier stehen wilde vom stunden
mit dem von gestern und achteinhalb also
fast in kompletter tag der weg ist bis
jetzt wird richtung muss die letzte tour
entstehen hilft andechs wir können ja
froh jetzt nicht vom altar stehen das
nicht so da läuft nicht aber trotzdem
soll es einfacher machen
erich ist schon seit dem frühen morgen
unterwegs nach ostende in belgien
spätestens um 16 uhr muss er ab lagen da
ist betriebsschluss
es wird knapp
ich brauchte ich brauch' ich brauch das
kribbeln das muss
muss immer knapp sein war mehr und dann
kriegt er sie nerven kribbeln
zähfließender verkehr ein unfall
erich hat mit den jahren so seine eigene
theorie entwickelt das subjektive
empfinden das als geistig die ampel ist
doppelt so lang am 8 oder rausgehen die
schranke zu oder es werde eine vordere
hat er macht langsam danach dauer nicht
langsam des lasters empfinde drei
stunden verspätung sind aufgelaufen
erich hat angst beim kunden in ostende
nicht rechtzeitig anzukommen nicht mehr
abladen zu können
dann ein echter stresstest jetzt guck
dir das an
jetzt fahren wir wieder zum nächsten
kreisverkehr wieder bitte wenden
was sagt das eigentlich
seine beiden navigationsgeräte streiten
sich erich glaubt jetzt an gar nichts
mehr
jetzt sucht er menschliche hilfe doch
auch die freunde und helfer müssen
diesmal nichts genaues erich ist macht
die zeit läuft ihm wieder weg er muss
auf die navis hören aber die streiten
noch
anhaltischen darin
erich fährt einfach weiter am ende
gewinnt er den kampf gegen die navis mit
drei stunden verspätung
doch zu seiner freude taucht noch ein
junger lagerist auf und lädt die druck
papiere ab und um der druck und der
ganze es ist jetzt alles weg
ich werde
kai hat inzwischen glück gehabt seine
hochzeits geschichte hat den lageristen
in essen erreicht er hat ihm ein
plätzchen zugewiesen wobei doch noch
abladen kann bei ist erleichtert
trotzdem beeilung er hat viel zeit
verloren
also ein zusammen heute 49 stunden sind
schon fast
der tag ist fast komplett also jeden tag
auch mal komplett verloren mit gestern
heute
gar nix wahrheit und sie hat auch ein
bisschen beeilen
eigentlich wollte er heute abend zu
hause sein das wird nichts mehr
er ist schon heilfroh dass er noch nicht
gefunden ist
morgen um 14 uhr ist der termin auf dem
standesamt
jetzt heißt es einen schlafplatz
schlugen seine lenkzeit ist abgelaufen
120 kilometer von zu hause entfernt die
muss er morgen früh nur schnell und
zweifelsfrei wurde jetzt schon mal sagen
ja nicht schlecht da steht schon
schwerer
ja
hast du natürlich probiert jetzt stecken
bleiben können wir nicht mehr
aber wir stecken da haben wir gleich
einen parkplatz
auch der dritte versuch schlägt fehl
kai hat schon handfeste
auseinandersetzungen und parkplätze
erlebt der in der anhand von vorne
wenn es dann soweit aber schon wie weit
der stelle zu kriegen war nachts auf der
autobahn die denkt viel über seine
familie nach seine frau und seine beiden
kleinen leiden darunter dass hier oft so
lange weg ist die eigentlich
selbstständig zu hause ist zu hause sie
alles machen tut und enteilt sich um
alles kümmert sich um alles kümmert du
brauchst ja eigentlich im prinzip nicht
kümmert und servicearbeiten du bist
einfach nur eine dumme arbeits drohne
die durch die gegend fährt kohle nach
hause schleppt da ist die frau total zu
hause auf sich allein gestellt und das
ist totale scheiße weil du kannst du dir
einfach die helfen weil du willst helfen
kannst aber nicht doch ganz plötzlich
wird er herausgerissen und zu einem
grübeln
der motor ist heißgelaufen er muss er
vor gericht sondern auf die standspur
ich hab nur mit kühlwasser verlust
das ist nicht schön
alle
das kühlwasser ist ausgelaufen
das leck ist hinter dem ersatz behälter
da kommt er jetzt nicht einen also
improvisieren
morgens um 3 uhr
hardy mal wieder an der leitplanke
während sein begleiter ein nickerchen
macht zieht er bilanz
er kennt den preis genau den er für
seinen job bezahlt man hatte auch keine
freundin mal da auch keine
freundschaftlichen kontakte man
schläft er allein weil
wenn
freunde sagen oder würden sagen wenn es
kommt leider vorbei kannst du nicht
machen weil irgendwo in europa oder auf
der straße unterwegs ist die sozialen
kontakte schlafen total ein
mit der zeit hat man ja aktien und dass
man alleine das war eigentlich alleine
hat man eben hat nur noch wirtheim zu
hause
das häuschen in ostfriesland ist
festlich geschmückt gerade mal sechs
stunden vor dem termin auf dem
standesamt ist er zu hause angekommen
viel später als geplant aber er hat es
geschafft
seit 9 uhr bereitet er sich vor die
frisur geht schnell
noch ist er ganz cool es habe ja als
zweiter versuch der wird wohl klappen
frau beckmann sagt er beim dritten mal
wird immer besser aber bei mir seit dem
zweiten ablehnen so ist der plan
wir werden sehen ich lieber dienst hose
t-shirt und mütter aber zur hochzeit und
sohn fest oder zu besonderen festen kann
man noch mal fragen was der extra
gekauft geht ja extra nur frauen neuer
lebensabschnitt neuer anzug
paul gibt sich betont lässig doch das
ändert sich als er endlich die braut sie
ist übersättigt beim anblick seines
handy er ist zu tränen gerührt sie
heiratet zum ersten mal
aber sie zeigt sich als die gefasst habe
[Musik]
tief durch
etwa zur gleichen zeit kämpft erich der
pechvogel um sein wochenende
trotz aller verzögerungen den unfällen
und staus könnte es wenigstens noch für
einen vollen tag zu hause erreichen
doch erich wittert ungemach
ich glaube wir kriegen gleich besuch mir
bleibt auch nichts erspart
das war's dann
ich hab's doch gewusst
von 1000 l sowie vanish fluchte hacke
hallo verkehrskontrolle fehlender
führerschein und fahrzeugpapiere
die überprüfung der ladungssicherung ist
obligatorisch alles vorschriftsmäßig
aber das dauert
nirgendwo nirgendwo wird einer
kontrolliert wenn er 15 stück schafft
für erich ist jetzt klar er wird hier
übernachten müssen seine arbeitszeit
läuft ab der polizei techniker rollt
noch einmal unter einen lkw mit akribie
leuchtet er den unterboden gravierend
aber manche machen ja ich mich außerdem
mögen elefanten der stoßdämpfer auf der
dritten achse rechts ist feucht des
unterrichts der müsste in letzter zeit
gewechselt werden
[Musik]
vor dem standesamt die obligatorischen
fotos dann wird es ernst
sind sie morgens die er einzugehen
an bord des aus freiem willen der
anwesenden konnten
[Gelächter]
damit hat kai auch den namen seiner frau
angenommen jetzt heißt er km manfred
moritz jakob
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
durch die polizeikontrolle hat erich
zwei stunden verloren nach hause
schaffte es heute nicht mehr
wieder kein wochenende mit der familie
erich hat das verdammt oft mitgemacht in
seinem tag erleben man gewöhnte strand
es ist heiß aber ein fenster kann er
nicht offen lassen weil sie sonst
einbrechen sagte ich bin hundemüde
schlafen vielleicht eine stunde oder 2
er ich will morgen früh noch einmal
angreifen will versuchen wenigstens im
laufe des samstags zu hause zu sein
dies sind die momente in denen auch ein
alter haudegen wie erich ins grübeln
kommt
schuldgefühle gegenüber frauen toter
kommen hoch wir haben hier nur eine
tochter sie hat einmal zu mir gesagt da
hatten wir meinungsverschiedenheiten und
er sagte zu mir vater als ich brauchte
warst du nicht da jetzt braucht ja auch
nichts mehr zu sagen das war wie ein
schlag ins gesicht vergessen denn der
satz fällt schwer mit solchen gedanken
einzuschlafen
[Musik]
die schicht mit dem
schwerlasttransporter hat gerade erst
begonnen
sie fahren in kolonne zur baustelle
eines riesigen windparks der konvoi aus
acht fahrzeugen stellt sich auf ein
letztes durchatmen vor der schwierigen
aufgabe die schwertransporter müssen
einzeln auf den notdürftig befestigte
nacker einfahren paradies last zu bis 30
meter lang und 130 tonnen schwer
andere wie ihn noch mehr da kann man
ganz schnell mal weg sagen und dann
braucht es einen kran um wieder flott zu
werden
höchste konzentration früh morgens um
fünf
hardy muss die bodenfreiheit immer
wieder neu justieren mit hilfe seiner
komplexen hydraulik sein ganzes
fahrerisches können wird jetzt auf die
probe gestellt der feldweg ist verdammt
eng
er muss die hinteren vier achsen extra
lenken mit einem funk lenker fuhr nach
links hinten nach rechts das vordere
fahrwerk fährt jetzt noch mal rum sowie
das auto und das hintere trainer
dahinter steckt damit eigentlich über so
ein board fahrer musik herausbringen
extra lenken
wer jetzt schwächelt nur eine sekunde
nicht aufpasst oder zu spät einschlägt
der lange dem acker und hält den ganzen
transport für das komplette wochenende
auf das schwierigste kommt immer am
schluss immer in den frühen
morgenstunden dies jetzt schon seit über
20 jahren
mit der arbeit an eine familie und
schafft für uns ein kleiner teil
und irgendwann wenn ich jedoch
gearbeitet habe denn für die zukunft
keine sorgen machen muss
er bleibe gross zu hause denn richtig
hoch nicht mehr diesen job machen
das abenteuer autobahn geht weiter drei
neue folgen die trucker stress unfälle
ads albtraum in der nacht auch sagen der
fahrer aus als wäre ich als hausmann
der rentner muss eine neue rolle erst
finden geht ihr ich wieder auf tour
nein mein mann gewohnt und seine
karossen der neue transporter macht
probleme
leck mich am arsch
sehen sie im nächsten sonntag die
trucker heißes pflaster autobahn
[Musik]